[Music]
and so now you've recently partnered
with vintage wine estate on the new
lifestyle platform called shop mr
wonderful how did that come about and
have you had a long-standing
relationship with vintage wine estates
it's a remarkable story and it's so
unusual how this came together i'll tell
it to you years ago on shark tank there
was a deal to to sell single serve wine
buy the glass in a container that was
sealed with nitrogen gas i was all over
it because i love that whole idea and i
thought this is such a big idea
i have got to go to the number one wine
bar on earth and that is costco and that
woman is annette alvarez peters
at the time she was the most powerful
woman on earth because she could buy
every pancho's complete
output and still not have enough wine
and so what i decided to do is take a
chance i figured who knows maybe she's a
shark tank fan maybe she saw the episode
last night at nine o'clock so through
nefarious techniques i got her cell
phone number because i know a lot of
people at work on the internet
and i called it and i left her a message
i knew she wouldn't answer because you
wouldn't know my number
and 20 minutes later
the phone rings
and it's annette alvarez peters on the
phone
and
i said to her annette i'm so honored you
called me back and she said you were
rude to barbara last night on shark tank
what do you want and i and she said look
i don't know if i like the single serve
idea but i'll let you pitch it to me i'm
going to hawaii i'm going to be one hour
in john wayne airport tomorrow i'll give
you 45 minutes of that time if you show
up at the airport lounge and i and bring
your wife with you i want to meet what
kind of woman would marry a guy like you
i said okay because she knew that my
wife was involved in blending the whites
and so
we flew there we flew to john wayne
airport we met with annette alvarez i
brought the prototype of the single
serve i really wanted to go into
partnership with costco on it
she had she had the prototype in her
hands
she turned it over it was above her
purse she turned it over to look at the
seal and it leaked into her purse oh was
she pissed and that was the end of that
idea it was over
but she said to me listen kevin you've
got a brand people trust your palate
they know you by the millions as the
wine guy
and if you want to play in the wine
business like i think you do because i
did
you can't ship a few cases
97 of wine in america is what she told
me is sold for under 15.99 a bottle you
have to be able to ship me millions of
cases millions of cases and you can't do
that on your own you're going to do some
kind of a vanity thing go buy a vineyard
make 25 000 cases and go out of business
go meet
terry wheatley and you know
the whole crew
over at vintage wine estates which we
already have a relationship with that's
pat roney and terry and her and that
whole crew there they service costco
they have logistics cut a deal with them
launch your wine then call me and that's
exactly what happened now why do wine
drinkers need a platform like shop mr
wonderful what benefits do they receive
so we have a huge both problem and
opportunity in america
this last two years
has proven that there's a huge appetite
direct to consumer in the wine business
the big challenge for the industry is
customer acquisition cost all of these
wine clubs all of these people that have
tried to do this all of these online
businesses have failed for one singular
reason
they cannot get their customer
acquisition cost below the lifetime
value of the customer no matter what
format they try
now
in that area i have a huge advantage
hundreds of millions of people
watch me every week on television i'm
very fortunate and they know me over all
of this time as someone who loves wine
curates wine makes wine and when it
comes to wine they understand
particularly those who bought from me
already when it comes to wine i have
their back
i know how to find the best ones at the
best price that people are going to like
i know the american palette whether it
be in southern florida or in upstate new
york or whether it's in washington state
on a new world pinot i know what they
like i know what they buy and i know why
they buy it and what price they're
willing to pay for it so the whole idea
of shop mr wonderful is to cr is to go
beyond just my own or very fine wines
and
curate some of the best wines on earth
for them at whatever price point they
want to work at if they want to work at
under 15 i'll find the best wine for
them if they want to be in the mid
market at that 45 or 49 to 69 i'm there
if they want to go into premium 150 200
i'm there i'm going to get them the best
wine at that price point that's the
whole idea and in partnering with
vintage estates which now i'm a
shareholder in because i you know they
went public recently and i decided to
take on a position as an equity
shareholder
we have 3 000 acres under production now
we're one of the largest consolidators
in the world
of wine production and logistics the
ability to ship it so i'm thinking
really big here because the pandemic has
proven to millions of americans they'd
like someone to ship them wine that's
good that they like at the right price
point they don't want to carry a 39
pound box of wine from the store we'll
ship it to them direct i think the
business opportunity is huge now how do
you go about picking the wines for the
platform i'm sure you have a team
helping you with this but why are they
selecting the wines they're selecting
no team i try them all myself
you can't you cannot [ __ ] people in
the wine business you have to be able to
be honest with people tell them what's
good and what's bad and you have to eat
your own cooking and you have to drink
your own wine
everything on that site i have
personally sampled every single drop
it's got my name on it
now how do you keep track of all that
kevin do you keep a journal do you use a
program of all your tasting notes
i do actually but my favorite is simply
a mole blonde writing pen
an ink nib pen
and a book that i keep my notes in
because you know i start every day when
the market closes at four o'clock i
always have a glass of white wine
montreshe sometimes i go old world shard
or i go new world shard off in my own i
always start with a glass of white and
when i'm doing that i'm always sampling
new shards because people send me all
kinds of output all kinds of wines i
have hundreds of wines to try and i also
talk to people about them first so i
have i operate five commercial sellers
around the world i buy wine futures i
trade them i have
partners we buy divorce sellers
sometimes when it comes to sampling wine
it's that glass of white at four and
then the decision which reds are we
going into with the meal are we going to
go pinot are we going to go cabs over
we're going to try zinn syrah where are
we going and in doing so i'm sampling
new wines with my friends and family and
asking their opinion too but ultimately
it's my decision and what do you look
for in a wine cabin does it depend on
the grape variety
no i really don't want people to get
tied up in varietals you know in america
we start with two verticals
chardonnay is the most popular white and
that's great
and cabernet sauvignon is the great
american red wine but what i've tried to
do over the years in communicating with
people whether i'm selling it on qvc or
whether i'm selling it on shop mr
wonderful is
if you like a red if you like a white
let me take you on a journey into other
ways of enjoying red wine because if you
like a great big spicy cabernet
sauvignon i bet i can find a zin that
you're just going to love and maybe
you've never tried a zin or how about a
meritage how about a blend that you've
never tried how about a new world pinot
how about a new world pinot with that
thanksgiving dinner even with a turkey
but i take copious notes and i do a lot
of video tasting notes that we post
of me tasting the wine describing the
experience what's good and bad about it
and i think after all this time
people have begin to trust me because
they bought for me they they like what
i'm giving them and i'm trying to expand
their horizons and the only way you can
do something like this is you've got to
love wine you've got to drink wine you
you have to breathe it
live it drink it taste it and be honest
about it and people will trust you what
are the types of questions that you ask
people if you're going to a dinner
you're hosting people at your house and
they'd say kevin pick me a bottle of
wine what are some of the questions that
you asked them to find that right bottle
for that specific individual
you know i don't ask them if they like
white or red i never asked that
i say what do you like in a wine what is
it that you like in anyone you they may
say i love sweet wines
and then i'll sneak into the cave and
i'll pull out a moscato
you know something to start the meal
with that classic beautiful petally
christmas
they just have to tell me the direction
to go and i will find multiple offerings
for them if they say something like oh i
like a big spicy wine or i only like red
wines i say forget about that i'm going
to get you a white one that you're going
to love even though you like reds
obviously i have the benefit of being
able to go into the cellar and pick out
all kinds of different wines but to me
it's like painting with a palette i say
to them trust me tonight we're going to
go on a wine journey we've prepared a
fantastic meal i try and do this with
eight to ten people and to me this is my
ultimate
beta testing because secretly i'm trying
wines on them that i'm gonna put on
you know shop mr wonderful i want to
hear what they say now it's a small
sample size but i have these dinners
like two three times a week so i might
get to 30 40 50 people and i'm gleaning
that information because i don't want
wine snobs i want people everyday people
that like trying wine and then i take
them on a journey and i take my notes
and then i go back to the wine makers
and say look
here's some notes i got because i've
really started to notice the difference
in the regions of what women like women
buy a lot of white wine what they buy in
florida versus what they buy in
california you know the unoaked shards
that really took off a couple of years
ago that really came out of florida in
those you know that that whole cuban
vibe that whole melting pot of getting a
much crisper mantra montrachet more like
less oaky less buttery that came out of
florida i saw it happen there
kevin you kind of mentioned the average
person
purchasing wine
why are sometimes people turned off by
wine is it that snobbery that they're
kind of afraid from that they kind of
shy away from getting involved in wine
in general
no they're nervous about it they're
nervous about taking it to a friend's
place for dinner they're nervous about
giving to their boss as a gift they're
nervous about opening it up and not
knowing anything about it it's the
biggest deterrent to trying wine
people are nervous because they think
you have to be a wine snob and i'm
really trying to push away from that we
shot mr wonderful i really really want
to know one thing what is your price
range what is your price range
not everybody can afford 150 bottle of
wine and if that's not where you want to
go we don't need to go there tell me
what you can afford and i will get you
the very best wines at that price point
at the same time give you opportunity to
sample different varietals that you've
never tried before
and then take your own notes and if you
want i will ship you another case of
wine along the lines of what you just
liked but i'm really really trying to
get people to expand their horizons by
just trusting me to to really marry them
to the right price point because i don't
want people to overspend what they can't
afford on wine is about family it's
about friends it's about conversation
it's about all of those things and
that's why i love it so much it's half
art half science blending is really
really hard getting it right is hard
being consistent one year to another
with a larry fine one chardonnay i've
got to make sure the people that love
that shard that buy it by the case are
not going to be disappointed in this
year's offering so there's work to be
done there but i love doing it and mr
wonderful one last question which
excites you more a great bottle of wine
or positive cash flow
[Laughter]
you know
you just reminded me of a story that
combines both of those together i don't
remember if you recall
the height of the pandemic
march april may that period when we were
all locked down i was at our home in
miami beach the beach for the first time
ever in 200 years was closed to people
nobody was on it the market was
incredibly volatile my portfolios of you
know start of the the operating company
we were having swings in the s p of 11
and 12
in an hour in an hour
and
you know that rule i have a glass of
white chardonnay at four o'clock i
remember the day the market went down
eleven and a half percent in the last
two hours
my portfolio was decimated i opened up
the shard
i poured it into a glass i went out on
the balcony and i looked out at the
beach
and i noticed there was a
whole
pod of pelicans
sitting
on the water close to shore inside of
the sandbar
and i saw this giant
giant uh it looked like a row boat it
was dark but it was a great white shark
and it had actually
done something they never did it came
within 10 feet of the shore because
there's no people i wasn't scared of
anybody
and it started eating the pelicans
with my chardonnay there and i thought
to myself
i thought i had a bad day look at those
guys
and
i know that's a crazy story and the next
day the market went up twelve percent it
was crazy you know on the ballot i don't
know why that all fits together but that
chardonnay was with the good times and
the bad times
chef wonderful here and i am totally
freaked out i'm the clumpy gas famous
winery in napa yeah i'm working on some
of my new recipes maybe i drank too much
wine because now i'm sitting beside dog
man and rabbit woman this is crazy i'm
freaking out
[Music]
if you like that video where did you see
my next one don't forget to click right
over here and subscribe